To look at the documentation, you'll simply type in
?cor.test. That will bring up this page. It looks
like cor.test takes two vectors x and y. And
then it will compute the correlation coefficient. It looks like
we have a couple methods for determining that coefficient
and we could either use pearson, kendall or spearman. For
our purposes, we'll be using the pearson method. So
your code might have looked like this. Writing this code,
we get a correlation coefficient of 0.0274. This
indicates that there's no meaningful relationship between the
two variables. A good rule of thumb is
that a correlation greater than 0.3 or less
than minus 0.3, is meaningful, but small. Around
0.5 is moderate and 0.7 or greater is
pretty large. Another way to compute the same
coefficient is to use this code. Here, I'm using
the width function for around the data frame. The width function let's us
evaluate an R expression in an environment
constructed from the data. Now, I know
I haven't shown you this function yet but I wanted to introduce it to
you. Running this bit of code we see that we get the same result.